[Music]
hello and welcome to the beyond us
series by the institute of art and ideas
my name is bernardo castro
and my name is fred matzer in this
series
we will explore four concepts that
underpin and define
the modern world knowledge competition
language and growth and in each episode
we're joined by a leading thinker to
help us
and hopefully you see each concept in a
new light
in the second episode of the series we
discuss
competition what it is how it differs
from cooperation
what role it plays in evolution and how
the concept of competition shapes
society here to discuss this fascinating
subject with us
is someone who has recently put forward
a theory that
if true means that our ability to
compete
for resources and survival has nothing
to do
with our grasp of reality yes i'm
talking about
donald huffman dawn it's lovely to speak
to you again it's been a little while
today we are going to talk about
something completely different than
what the tone of our usual conversations
uh
is something a little less metaphysical
but with metaphysical significance which
is
the concept of competition so before i
even start
welcome to this episode dawn thank you
very much
bernardo it's great to be with you and
fred
thank you thank you dawn great to have
you
let's dive right in then
we are talking in this series about four
key concepts
um that sort of drive our society
one of them is competition and we
thought it's only
appropriate to talk to you about
competition because competition
is one of the driving forces behind the
evolution of the species
on which much of of your work is based
and not only does this concept have
enormous
yeah even prehistorical significance
because it has come to shape what we
what we are essentially it also drives
for instance our economic system
which is largely based on competition so
before we get into the details don
i wanted to ask you how do you see
competition what is
competition and why has it become so
important for us human beings
right so the framework that i'll
address that in is evolutionary game
theory
which is a mathematical model for
evolution by natural selection
and there there's the notion of
different strategies
so you have different strategies for
interacting with
so think about a game where you have a
bunch of players and you're you're
playing a game of chess or playing a
game of what whatever it might be and
you can have different strategies
and um evolutionary evolution doesn't
restrict the strategies to just
competitive strategies right you can
have cooperative strategies
and and so in evolutionary game theory
what we
do is is study uh what will happen
when you have different kinds of
strategies interacting so
so i'll give a concrete simple example
so there's um suppose that there there
are resources around
uh and there's a dove strategy
for collecting those resources a dove
when two doves meet um and then there's
a a resource there
they will flip a coin and politely
whoever wins the flip
um gets the resource and the other one
they don't fight there's no competition
they're they're so they're devs okay
that's one strategy that you could have
and uh it turns out that uh if
everybody's a dove
no one gets hurt and uh it's quite nice
everything goes quite well
but now consider another strategy um
called the hawk
strategy and hawks whenever they meet
any other player they always escalate
they
they will fight until someone loses
and uh and so whereas a dove will never
fight
okay so so what happens is that
if everybody's a dove that's a very fit
strategy
and cooperation works very very well the
problem is
that if you're a hawk and everybody else
is a dove
then you will always win right so every
time you meet a dove the dove backs down
you get all the resources and the dove
loses
and and and there's no harm to the hawk
now on the other hand if everybody's a
hawk depending how on how much damage
you get when you fight
it could be very very bad news to to be
a hawk so so what you see
is there's no such thing as a good
strategy or a bad strategy
the strategies are what they call
frequency dependent
it depends on what the other players are
doing and what strategies they have so
so if everybody is cooperating then it
just turns out mathematically
that being a hawk is more fit in the
sense that you will win
and and get more more payoffs if
everybody's a hawk
then it actually might be better to be a
dove
because you're not getting all the
injuries that the
hawks are right and so so it turns out
you can
by by playing with how much injury you
get when you fight
versus how much payoff you get when you
you when you win
you can switch the proportion the
long-term proportion of
hawks and doves and and
so so that gives you just a feel in a
simple game
that that evolution isn't just about
cooperation
or just about competition it's about
strategies
and and it turns out there's no such
thing as the right strategy and so
so it's not the case that competition is
the right strategy
right that's just too simplistic it
depends on what the other players
are are doing and what the payoffs are
so it's really
quite nuanced and so what you what you
find in evolutionary theory
is it doesn't just say we always compete
no we we
there's lots of examples in nature of
cooperation
and we can talk about them um and so it
that that can evolve cooperation can
evolve
um but but maybe i should stop and let
you um
go where you want indeed competition
with other creatures don has clearly
been key to our survival as species but
what about the role
of cooperation within the human species
isn't this
something overlooked as an equally
defining feature
of human life not at all in evolutionary
theory um
cooperation is actually an important
strategy
and there's lots of interesting examples
of of that strategy
in humans and and in other species maybe
i can start with
another species just for a moment which
is which is simpler
um is the belding ground squirrel
and these ground squirrels uh you know
they they have burrows and so forth they
pop up and look around
and uh they're of course on the menu for
a lot of um
predatory birds and other animals so
what happens is that if uh
one of the belting ground squirrels sees
say a hawk flying
uh it will put out a shriek
and now that shriek warns the other
ground squirrels that might
not have been aware of the hawk uh and
they sent
they can go scurrying to their their
holes but this
is also a call that says dinner is right
here right but when i'm shrieking i'm
giving
you know i'm drawing attention to myself
so so
there is an altruistic behavior so
how did that altruistic behavior
evolve now the the a standard story with
an evolutionary theory
is based on the notion of what what's
sometimes called the selfish gene
right so so that so of course that's
just
you know a figure of speech the genes
have no emotions or anything like that
but it is it's that genes the idea is
that
instead of looking at things
evolutionarily from the point of view of
the organism
being the central feature look at it
from
the point of view of genes being the
central feature and whether a gene gets
passed to the next generation as being
sort of the central
central feature guiding evolution and
and the idea then is this
that if there was a gene that coded for
that kind of
behavior where you give a shrink when
when there's danger
it there is a chance of course that that
squirrel that gives the shrink will die
there's an increased chance but if that
gene is in all the other squirrels or
most of the other squirrels
then the other squirrels have a better
chance of surviving
with that gene and that's the point
those if the other
scrolls have the gene then sacrificing
one squirrel
could be worth the you know the
punishment
the worth worth the cost uh if it saves
a bunch of other squirrels that have the
gene
so so in this point of view and again
i'm not saying this is the final word or
the right way to think about this is
just the
the best way that we have it right now
in our best scientific theory
the idea is that the the gene is quote
unquote
willing to sacrifice you to let the gene
itself get passed on into the next
generation
through others and so this is sort of a
deflating
notion of altruism that we get from from
evolutionary theory that
that it our feelings of altruism that we
might
put to some higher uh deeper
moral sense is just genes pulling the
strings of our heart to do what
what they want our bodies to do so that
the genes will have a better chance of
getting into the next generation now
again i'm not saying that this is right
i'm saying that this is the best science
that we have so far right this is and
if we don't like it then it's up to us
as scientists
to you know try to come up with a deeper
deeper theory
um that that is mathematically precise
um so what you could do is take what i'm
saying today as a
as a call for a better theory if we
don't like this theory yeah
like the cells in our body that are
dying because they want to maintain
the vitality of the body to keep us
alive
the willingness on the cell level to die
to keep the integrity of the body intact
that's exactly right i mean every day
about
60 billion cells in your body are killed
yeah 60 billion and and many of them are
through apoptosis where i mean
you tell them to die and they commit
harry carey
and they they're gone and and this is
all so
here's a case again of cooperation the
ultimate altruism
death for the for the whole body and
then then you're creating new cells
um 60 billion new cells on on average
every day
to to to replace them and
you can think of your body in that sense
as quadrillions of organisms
separate each cell is an organism that
have agreed
to cooperate not to fight
or or to at least reduce the fighting
and one way of thinking about cancer is
um
cancer are our cells that have sort of
um decided
to break the pact that they they no
longer you know
want to uh be told when they have to die
and and in fact
cancer cells are immortal in a sense
they they they reproduce
so they they're breaking the pack so
cancer happens when we don't cooperate
so
so you could see that in some sense
every multi-cellular
organism is embodying
an incredible amount of cooperation so
so in some sense cooperation is is at
least as important if not more important
than competition
and so interesting when you realize that
what you mentioned
the cancer is a as in a way the parasite
on the system
so that's the one that is in the
attitude of competition while the other
uh cells basically sing and acquire
are seeing are as operating as a unit
that are willing to die
to keep the integration going of the
integrated system of the body
so that's in the body we have both
systems we have the cooperative part
and we have the competing part that's
right and and
i think it's it's quite interesting
just as you know looking at it
scientifically that that both are
involved
but i think what this discussion
illustrates uh don
very clearly is that a
seemingly purely biological concept such
as
competition or or cooperation as well
it has all kinds of higher order
philosophical implications and i think
your work illustrates this more than any
other because
what you're basically saying is that
evolution which operates
through the forces of competition and
maybe some cooperation
is what sets our view of reality is what
determines
what we perceive as real so in a sense
this biological concept of competition
it rises
up the all the way to determining what
we consider real and true
could you comment on that absolutely and
and this is a bit of a surprise it's
it's
sort of counter-intuitive most of us
including my
my very um you know esteemed colleagues
in in cognitive neuroscience and
evolution
tend to think that um evolution
surely would shape our senses to show us
truths about reality right the idea is
that
organisms that see reality more
accurately
should have a competitive advantage over
those who see reality less accurately
and thus they're more likely to survive
and pass on their genes which code for
the more accurate perceptions and
and so after thousands of generations of
that we can be quite confident that
we're the offspring of those who saw
more accurately and so we see more
accurately
and and again no one thinks that we see
all of reality truthfully
but we see those aspects of reality that
we need to survive
in our niche is the idea and that seems
imminently plausible who could argue
with it but but i decided to
to check more carefully i mean the nice
thing about
scientific theories is not that they're
true but they're precise
and so we don't have to wave our hands
and debate and fight and so forth
you can go prove theorems and evolution
by natural selection
um whether or not it's true is precise
and there's evolutionary game theory so
we can go see what that theory
actually says and so i you know first um
you know i'm not a mathematician so i
first worked with some graduate students
10 12 years ago and we did simulations
just to see what would happen because we
could write down evolutionary game
simulations and i thought maybe
you know it would be um maybe it takes
too much time and energy to compute the
truth maybe
there are selection pressures not to see
the truth because it's just you know
it's a lot of time and energy maybe
we'll
have heuristics and shortcuts because of
that well and
the simulation showed that that yeah
that plays a role but
the simulation showed something deeper
um and this was uh brian marion and
justin mark who who did the simulations
um
what they what we discovered was that
it's
the the payoffs when i talked about the
hawks and the doves and you get certain
payoffs for
winning and you know penalties for
losing and so forth
those payoff functions they're the heart
and soul of
of these games right and what we
discovered is
the payoff functions do depend on the
state of the world
but almost surely those payoff functions
erase information about the structure of
the world
that's the key point i'll say it again
the payoff functions which
guide whether you're going to survive or
not they do depend on the state of the
world
and its structure but they almost surely
erase
all information about the structure of
the world
and since evolution is shaping our
senses
based on the payoff functions and the
payoff functions have no information
about the structure of the world
there's no way for evolution to shape
our senses to see
the true structure of the world whatever
it might be it's that
it's that simple and so so it's a
theorem
of evolution by natural selection the
probability
that any of our perceptions space and
time colors objects
no structure of our perceptions reflects
true structures of objective reality
almost surely
the probability of zero that we see
reality as it is
that now again that's i'm not saying
that that's true
i'm saying that it's a theorem of
evolution by natural selection
so so as a scientist again uh you know
my attitude is i i
love our scientific theories because
they're precise
and they they encode untold
years of work by brilliant people that
have really done their homework
and tried to write down with
mathematical precision what they've
learned
and it's the best we've got but it
doesn't mean it's right
so so all we can do as scientists is to
look at our best scientific theories
i respect them for their their
brilliance
and their precision and then as a
scientist i also pay them the honor of
trying to destroy them
by by finding where they you know might
have holes where they might have flaws
not not in any negative sense i mean i'm
i'm going to respect the theory that i
destroy
because it's they're brilliant theories
but the idea is to try to then get to
the next level
so so about 120 years ago
many physicists were quite convinced
that
um newtonian physics was the final word
in physics
and there was a sort of a complacency
among many not all but many physicists
that you know it's been done
and we shouldn't encourage bright young
people to go into physics
they should go into some other fields
there's there's just a few little things
to mop up in physics
well there's a different attitude that
you can have which is
newtonian physics has been great for
several centuries
but we should be always looking to try
to break it and if you've been looking
to try to break it you're going to make
progress more quickly it turns out it
needed to be broken and
you know eventually in plank in 1900 and
einstein in 1905 found you know the ways
to break through
eventually um and and so my attitude as
a scientist is that we should just
assume
it should just be a matter of assumption
that our current theories are wrong
not trivially wrong right these are the
works of brilliant people who won nobel
prizes and so forth it's not trivially
wrong
these are and so the current generation
has to study these theories
very very carefully and then it's going
to be hard work
to come up with the next step because
you know you have to so
this is not trivial so so that's that's
my attitude
in all this is is that um when i'm
looking at evolutionary theory and i'm
saying that it
um entails we so don't see reality as it
is
that seems to be a theorem of evolution
now one can then say well i think that
we do see reality as it is
or at least some aspects of reality in
that case then
you owe the scientific community a
deeper theory
what is that deeper reality how
come in that deeper view of reality it's
possible
for creatures like us to see some of
reality
and also you have to explain why in this
deeper theory
it looks from the point of view of
evolution by natural selection
like you can't see reality as it is you
have to explain
the emergence of evolutionary theory as
a special case of this deeper theory
so so and that's what i'm up to i'm
looking for a deeper theory
in my case i'm looking for a theory in
which consciousness is fundamental
but that deeper theory then
might allow that some of our perceptions
are true
despite the theorem that i've got with
by the way the theorem
i should give proper credit chetan
prakash my my uh
long time friend and collaborator for
since the 1980s
um was the one that i took this to when
i said you know we got these simulations
it looks like
you know i said yeah i think there's a
theorem here so he and i discussed it
but but he's the mathematician chaitan
brought it through and we have a couple
papers that were just published um
recently
that have the theorems so
so now what chaitan and i and others are
looking for is a deeper theory of
consciousness
and the dynamics of consciousness which
um
then the the job we have to do is to
show how this deeper theory
gives rise to what we call space and
time
and physical objects what we call matter
what if the space and time and physical
objects aren't the fundamental reality
consciousness is the fundamental reality
then we need a theory of consciousness
that's absolutely mathematically precise
that says what the dynamics of
consciousness is
and explains exactly how space time
emerges say as a user interface
that some conscious agents use to
interact with all the other conscious
agents
and within that interface we have to
then show
that we get evolution by natural
selection as
the the interface view of this dynamics
of consciousness
in other words evolution financial
selection is what
the dynamics of consciousness looks like
viewed through the restricting lens
of our space-time interface and if we
can't by the way
my theory of consciousness cannot be
taken seriously
until we can do that until we can show
how to get space-time emerging
and get evolution by natural selection
emerging
also by the way special relativity
general relativity quantum field theory
until we can get those things emerging
there's no reason
for any scientist to take a theory of
consciousness
seriously right there's and and the
reason is
there's nothing for them to take
seriously there's nothing on the table
so of course we always have to have
a debate of ideas and and even
mathematically imprecise ideas there's
a time for that in science but but for
scientists to take anything seriously
it has to go beyond you know sophomore
discussions over beer
about what our ideas are it's got to be
mathematically precise so
so until we have something that's
mathematically precise on the table
there's literally nothing for the
scientists to react to
we there's and they should pay no
attention don
thank you may i ask uh wait as you know
i'm i
both know i'm not a scientist but a
quality of competition
is to exclude it's a process of
exclusion of
in in in consciousness at excludes
cooperation is a a
thought process an attitude
consciousness
of inclusion and when we look about
consciousness as something that is
non-local that doesn't know time
nor space but is perhaps the womb of
time and space
and we look from the infinite
consciousness
we see time space as a coexisting
dynamic process that goes from high
density to the
to the edges of the universe where it is
very thin
and where you see that everything
transforms and
interacts from that perspective
and that attitude wouldn't you think
that you come
closer to to being aware
of the fundamentals of nature and
reality
i i'm betting that you're right i'm
and that's why i'm working on a theory
of consciousness in which
uh we get a mathematical model of
consciousness and and
in which i i anticipate that that
cooperation
will be a key aspect of it and i'm
thinking also
um exploration cooperation and
exploration
yeah one thing that see
if we take consciousness as fundamental
and we're trying to develop a scientific
theory there are two or three
important questions that we have to
answer one is
what is consciousness up to right if
you're saying conscience is fundamental
and it and there's and it's dynamic why
why don't conscious agents just all sit
around drinking beer and uh having a
good time what what
what is the dynamic of consciousness and
and why
what is so there's got to be some really
deep
principle here right we
that's right some some telos that's
right that's driving it and second
once we have that we we also have to
explain exactly how space time
arises right space time is
our framework that you know right right
now physicalism
which is the dominant view in science is
the idea
that space time is fundamental
and and objects in space time are the
fundamental reality
well we have to explain if consciousness
is fundamental how space time emerges
and physical objects
now on the first question what is the
dynamic
of consciousness and why the the right
answer is i don't know
but and i only have because of the
poverty of my imagination
i only have one idea right now which um
which
so i'll throw it out there but it's more
as a challenge for people to
to try to come up with better ideas
right so
the idea that i've got um is
and my team is working on is is based on
girdle's incompleteness theorem
and i won't go into the details of
girdles incompleteness theorem but but
what what girdles in completeness
theorem basically entails
is that there is no end to the
exploration
of mathematical structure no matter how
much mathematical structure you explore
and find you've only just begun
that's sort of a summary of what girdles
incompleteness theorem entails
i mean i could tell you exactly what the
theorem states but it's i think it's
not relevant right now so there's this
fundamental open-endedness
to mathematical structure and
if so there's two things i need to say
about how that applies here first
when we study consciousness in the
scientific field of psychophysics and
i've studied psychophysics for decades
we study conscious experiences with
mathematical precision and with
experiments
and what we find is that all conscious
experiences have mathematical structure
when you see a ball you're seeing
something with a geometry
the colors are part of a color space
with
similarity structure on between the
colors every conscious experience
has structure there's more to experience
than mathematical structure
but there's not less and so one way to
think about it is
that conscious experiences
and mathematics are related like
an organism and it's bones a creature in
its bones
you can't have the creature at least
your vertebrate
without the bones but the bones aren't
the whole creature
and so that's the way i'm thinking about
mathematics and consciousness
there's no consciousness without
mathematics but there's more to
consciousness than just mathematics
now if that's the case and if
consciousness
is all that there is so consciousness is
fundamental reality
then there's nothing else for
mathematics to be about
mathematics is about the possible forms
of consciousness
in that case what girls incompleteness
theorem is telling us is
there's an inexhaustible exploration of
the possible varieties of consciousness
i call this girdles candy store so
girdles candy store
is you know there's this infinite
variety
of possible conscious experiences that
in principle
could never be exhausted we could never
come to the exploration
end of the exploration of it and so
that's what consciousness is about it's
the the kid in the candy store
this one is great now what's the next
one and so forth now
now that sounds all fun and light and so
forth but now let me
pull the dark side or the the the other
side of that
to go to the next structure
the next conscious experience the that's
beyond anything that you've ever had
before you have to let go of what you
already know
and that can be painful
and very very scary uh you know in the
simplest case
the kid that has the little chocolate
and you say well there's this other one
over here
the kid might go you know i like don't
force me to have that i want the
chocolate do i want to stick with what i
know i
i want to eat the chocolate and if you
tell the kid but there are other really
good candies out there that might even
be better than chocolate
he might not believe you now so there's
there's going to be i think
this this this is right this entails a
process that's both
a fun exploration and also terrifying at
the same time
because you're having to let go of what
you already know
don before i ask you the the six million
dollar question
to wrap this up i i can't resist but
make a comment on your reference to
reference to godo's incompleteness
theorem um
i'm sure you know this but for the
benefit of the audience if you go
through godot's
proof of that theorem you will see that
where he stumbles on the incompleteness
the part that forces the incompleteness
of knowledge
is when the system tries to make a
statement about itself
there is where it goes wrong so to say
that's where that's that's what is
always incomplete you the system will
either be wrong
about what it says of itself or it will
not say
everything there is to be said about
itself and when you relate that to
consciousness
the the match is almost poetic right
it's it's
consciousness never being able to say
everything there is to be said
about what it is i find i find this a
fantastic idea
now the the six million uh dollar
question uh
dawn i think if we step back and and and
contemplate the discussion we had today
and then we look at our society um
the values uh that underlie competition
or competition itself has a value it uh
it motivates ideologies uh it
steers our very economic system um you
know capitalism is largely driven by
competition it's seen as a fundamental
positive force if explored correctly
some see this idea of competition as
as fundamental in nature as embedded
in nature itself but the discussion
today makes it clear that
it it it is likely an emergent
something or at least it may be an
emergent
something that emerges emerges out of a
system
in which competition is not
fundamentally built in now if that is
the case do you see
um implications for
how we should best approach life how we
should best
interact with one another organize our
society and even our economic systems
well yes i think that
if the idea of limited resources and
therefore necessary competition
is not fundamentally correct suppose
that that's just an artifact of our
space-time interface
and that a deeper theory of
consciousness indicates that that's not
correct
and that there are in some sense
unlimited or much less limited resources
then i would say once we get that
scientific theory
of consciousness and
we're able to reverse engineer space
time because space time isn't reality
it's just an interface once we're able
to step behind that
interface and play with space time
itself the actual
play with space and time warp space and
time the technologies
that will be unleashed will make
everything that we've seen so far seem
trivial
and we might eventually then have
technologies in which the notion of
limits of resources is no longer
relevant
i mean it it so so yes there could be a
very
practical aspect to this if it turns out
that the realm of consciousness
is not limited and we're able to reverse
engineer the spacetime interface and
understand how consciousness is related
to our interface
and we can now play with our interface
instead of being stuck in it
and limited by it we can play with it
then we may eventually find that there's
no need for
this kind of competition except in the
sense that i i like to compete with
someone on the tennis court right
it's a friendly competition and it's fun
and then afterwards we have a beer
right john mayer may ask say
if we with what is six seven billion
people now
if we would help and change our neural
pathways into moving to more
let's not compete but let's compare with
care in order to share
with care because we help to implant
in people's mind that we are living
together dynamically
in a cooperative system where
we do not need to compete that we would
find ourselves later in a completely
different evolution these of course goes
together with
limited wanting to have all kinds of
stuff
it goes together with taking more
nutrition out of water
out of breeding by chewing more
we would need less nutrients and so on
and so on you know we
basically you go from stress that
is a side effect of competition
from which we all suffer now to a more
slow life
with a different outcome what are your
thoughts when i just little bits it uh
i'm fantasizing about this uh road and
what can we do about this together
well i i agree and i think that that it
is possible that and that a theory of
consciousness
may be a an important way forward on on
this
in which we find out that space time and
its limitations
are not fundamental and there's this
deeper realm that that's not limited
well just to give an example of of the
kind of possibilities
um all of modern technology
in modern society is based on
electricity
we didn't have that 200 years ago
right we had people playing with iron
filings and these funny little rocks
and like we had lightning strikes and so
forth
we had no idea the power
that could be released if we understood
those rocks and those iron filings and
those
those strikes of lightning it took
brilliant people
centuries of hard work and luck
and then finally james clerk maxwell
writing down what everybody had learned
in in a few
equations that then unleashed modern
society right now
we're talking like this because we got a
deeper insight into
something that we didn't understand
and had at least incredible power and
the idea is that is a mere warm up once
we
really understand how consciousness
works and the unlimited resources beyond
space-time but we have to
have our equivalent of maxwell's
equations for this
then i think the notion of limitations
may just be something we laugh about
in the past that that was just like we
laugh about having to light a candle to
see into your house tonight
right why don't you just flip on the
switch i mean there's unlimited
electricity and light
we will laugh at our current limitations
about food and and so forth in
competition um but there's
some serious work i mean it took a
maxwell maxwell was a genius
of the level of a newton and an einstein
i mean he was he was he was a serious
genius
we're going to need a bunch of
researchers to do something the
equivalent of that and
i'm so i'm hoping that there's someone
who can do this
it's not me i'm not that smart but but
someone who's got the power
to take consciousness and turn into a
truly
deep mathematical theory and then
unleash what you're talking about
um which is you know fred the the
possibility of
no limits of resources and also maybe a
new understanding of what kind of
creatures we really are
that we don't need to compete that was
an illusion that we had to compete
i would love for it to come out that way
gentlemen
this is an incredibly fascinating
conversation certainly for me
we have to leave it on this optimistic
note for the future i could sit here
together with fred and talk to you down
for another hour
easily maybe we should do this sometime
in the future
but in the meantime thanks so much for
being here and talking to us i've
enjoyed a lot
fred any final words well i'm most
grateful for
don it was fascinating and very
instructive to me
new insight and was lovely to reconnect
with you thank you so much
thank you fred and bernardo both
bernardo as well of course yeah
thank you my friend and thanks to all
the listeners for
sticking around with us in this in this
episode i hope you've enjoyed it
and more is coming in the next couple of
weeks there will be more
of the four big themes of our society
in which fred and i will discuss with
another guest
so see you then take care
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv